welcome back to cbs this morning a
high-profile
critic of russian president vladimir
putin has been
awakened from a medically induced coma
after he was apparently
poisoned with a nerve agent alexei
navalny suddenly fell
ill last month he was taken to germany
for treatment president putin
faces new pressure from the
international community to investigate
this morning the u.n human rights chief
is demanding russia's full
cooperation charlie tagada is in london
charlie how
is navalny doing at this point well
anthony doctors say his condition is
improving he's responsive they're
gradually trying to get him off the
ventilator but they said at this point
it's too early to tell what kind of
long-term damage has been done from what
they're describing
as a severe poisoning
out of the coma but not out of trouble
yet and investigators say beyond all
doubt president vladimir putin's
fiercest opponent
is the victim of a chemical nerve agent
attack novichok
his team believes someone slipped poison
into his tea
before his flight to siberia last month
on board passengers said navalny started
moaning and screaming in pain
he was airlifted to berlin after initial
treatment in a russian hospital
german toxicology reports later found
unequivocal proof
he was poisoned with novichok the same
military
nerve agent used to poison former
russian double agent sergey skripal
and his daughter yulia in salisbury
england in 2018.
one of a group of nerve agents developed
solely in russian labs
says chemical weapons expert hamish to
bretton gordon
i think the world is is really looking
at putin and the russian regime
it has all the hallmarks all the
operating procedures
of a russian state-sponsored
assassination or
just to get this fellow out of the way
the 44 year old opposition leader has
been a thorn in the side of president
putin for years
he's been arrested more than a dozen
times for organizing
anti-putin protests the kremlin has
dismissed
allegations of innova chalk poisoning as
absurd
the agent attacks the body by crippling
the nervous system
and just a tiny amount is enough to kill
well very quickly
you would experience shortness of breath
because the nerves that control the
muscles that control your lungs
would shut down and it's like
drowning which they say is the worst way
to go
brighton gordon says navalny is lucky to
be alive
and while he may have escaped with his
life one goal
has been achieved it's unlikely he'll
ever return to russia
again now in addition to the u.n human
rights chief calling for a full
investigation
she called the number of poisonings
inside and outside of russia
over decades profoundly disturbing
tony all right charlie dagger to force
in london trolley thank you very much
profoundly disturbing is the right term
for it happens just as putin gets a
referendum passed allowing him to be
president until 2036. yeah
and the resistance in russia with him
out of the country has lost
its most powerful voice i think and he's
been speaking about it for years guys
that he
that he knows his life is in danger it
just mattered so much to him that he was
going to carry on
just glad that he came out of the coma
yeah very glad we keep following it
didn't expect that to happen